Hey, you!
Huh?
You should be careful
of that sort of stuff.
What sort of stuff?
I'm talking about Kana and Erika.
What?
Anyone who makes friends
with a transfer student...
They usually have ulterior motives.
The class losers make friends with new
students because they have no friends.
Today we're playing soccer for gym class.
There!
Huh?
Well, whether you're good at soccer or not
has nothing to do with life.
Arf!
Huh. Yamada might actually be cool.
-Here it comes, Watanabe!
-Huh?
Kick it in the goal!
What a loser!
Never mind! He's awful.
No, no. Don't get mad.
Well, that was embarrassing.
What? What's going on?
You better watch out
around that transfer student.
She's telling everyone
that you two are bullying her.
-That's horrible!
-Unbelievable!
She's a scary woman.
She can lie as easily as she can breathe.
That's what you're doing!
Babu?
You're the one with the worst personality!
Hey, sorry!
It's 'cause you were just standing there.
I can't stand it anymore.
I'm sick of all of you!
Babu!
This is so cool
Ouch...